hey some folks out there got a little
upset after the election they're a
little bit freaked out some of them are
a lot freaked out some of your way to
sucked into that vortex I'll just tell
you but hey here's an idea try to find
somebody just be nice to them today some
people are really thinking things are
going to be worse than they are and
they're freaking out man I mean the fear
is amazing out there among some of the
Hillary followers so I'm something you
really think stuff's going to happen
it's not going to happen and it's just
because you're young and you haven't
lived through this before it's okay
it's going to be all right it really is
you're going to be all right and a world
is not coming to an end and the world
wouldn't have come to an end if it was
the other way around if the other if
Hillary had won so you're going to be
all right and you know here's what you
need to be any concentrate on your life
and you need to be careful what you're
putting into your brain I mean watching
these watching these news channels just
day in and day out every little nuance
every little nasty thing in the whole
election cycle it's just enough to
destroy your spirit and you really you
really need to get away from that it's
just you just live your life mad because
you watch that stuff all the time and
whether you're left or whether you're
right I mean you spend all your time be
a man life is too short man really
seriously hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show